voilà le quartier des étangs
au cœur d'olny-sous-bois au nord de
Paris une trace des émeutes qui ont
secoué le pays
il a fallu contourner les barricades de
feu faire le tour quoi la nuit Christian
parcourt les routes comme chauffeurs de
transport privé aujourd'hui dans la
cinquantaine et il a grandi dans cette
banlieue par iciienne déjà il y a des
décennies la relation entre jeunes et
policiers étaient difficiles une tension
qui a perduré toutes ces années
pendant des années des années
et qui fait en sorte qu'aujourd'hui on
se retrouve encore là
comme plusieurs banlieues
Aulnay-sous-Bois a été le théâtre des
meute après la mort de Naël tué par un
policier
un camion a même été volé avant d'être
incendié des autorités en ont à pied à
la responsabilité des parents si
Christian a demandé à ses enfants de
rester à la maison pour d'autres ce
n'est pas évident
pour ceux qui travaillent dur comme ça
la nuit vous laissez vos enfants ou
laissez vos deux enfants parce que de
toute façon le boulot vous l'avez pas
ici dans le quartier vous l'avez
ailleurs et la priorité d'un apparence
c'est pas assez éduquer les enfants
d'accord mais cela ramener à manger
payer la maison
démarrer des femmes du quartier sont
tout de même descendus dans la rue pour
mettre fin à des violences d'une ampleur
qu'elles avaient rarement vu on comprend
on déplore voilà mais c'est pas de cette
façon qu'il faut manifester la colère il
y avait une cause de départ qu'on
défendait tous on a tous cette cause en
commun mais là c'est la course
dans le sens où moi j'ai brûlé ça toi
qu'est-ce que tu as brûlé c'est plus un
challenge un challenge en fait je vois
pas où est la révolte dans ça dans
brûler notre lieu d'habitation dans des
trucs qui nous appartient à nous ce qui
nous sera nous
on voit pas trop l'intérêt et c'est même
courageux de ta part rejoindre la
situation c'est finalement calmée mais
les conversations se poursuivent dans
les rues du quartier
pour ne pas en arriver là parce que la
colère grande toujours chez certains
jeunes au-delà des relations avec les
policiers des facteurs sociaux
économiques alimentent les frustrations
à l'endroit des autorités à Aulnay le
taux de chômage est environ deux fois
plus élevé que celui de la France près
du tiers de la population vit sous le
seuil des pauvreté
du quartier c'est que nous c'est voilà
pourquoi les gens sont frustrés quoi
mais non c'est banlieues le sentiment
d'appartenance à la nation est faible et
le sentiment d'appartenir à un monde
différent de celui de la société globale
est très important ce sociologue c'est
penché sur le cas d'Aulnay-sous-Bois
après des grandes émeutes de 2005
ségrégation pauvreté criminalité selon
lui les dizaines de milliards d'euros
que l'État a investi pour rénover les
édifices non pas permis de régler les
problèmes de fonds auxquels ces
quartiers sont confrontés les personnes
qui veulent s'en sortir ils ont souvent
le réflexe de quitter ces cités pour et
ceux qui arrivent au contraire sont des
gens avec de faits qualifications de
faibles diplômes et donc la pauvreté
se renforce dans ces cités tout par an
de quartier rêve que de partir du
quartier pourtant moi j'avais cette
envie avant mais en vieillissant on se
sent bien dans le quartier aussi
aujourd'hui il est très impliqué au sein
de cette association implantée au cœur
du quartier des résidents et
transmettent à la jeunesse leur passion
pour le hip-hop et la danse
[Musique]
rien faire là on se retrouve avec des
gens comme nous et on peut pratiquer des
choses qu'on apprécie du coup ça nous
permet de pas tomber dans des choses qui
sont mauvaises
une mission qui ne se fait pas sans défi
avec les fermetures liées à la pandémie
certains jeunes sont définitivement
parti
Christian la musique a été centrale pour
affronter les difficultés auxquelles
sont confrontées les résidents du
quartier plus que jamais ils croient
qu'il est crucial d'appuyer les grosses
communautaires qui permettront à
d'autres jeunes d'emprunter un chemin
similaire
[Musique]
nous au niveau de la danse hip-hop toute
mauvaise énergie on l'a transformé en
positif